our next question is from Noel hi
minimalists my name is Noel and I'm from
Boulder Colorado and over the past
couple months I have decided that I want
to embrace Embrace a life of Simplicity
and minimalism and so I fell fell across
your podcast and I've been decluttering
my bedroom as I rent a room from a
family and I'm in grad school and I'm
finding that as a declutter there are
many items that I don't like the
aesthetic of because I bought them
either on a on sale or was trying to
embrace some sort of style that I saw on
social media or Pinterest that was
trendy but they are not me and now I
want to slowly replace those items um to
something that is much better quality
and more Timeless but how do I go about
replacing items in my space in a way
that doesn't Tu me back into
consumerism would love your opinion
thanks I don't know that I have an
opinion about this but I have some
insights based on my own experience
here the line she said I bought these
things because they're on sale they're
not aesthetically pleasing but then she
added to it they are not me I'll tell
you this even if you find the thing that
is the most aesthetically pleasing it is
still not you you are you and you are
complete even in an empty room and
therefore if an object does not enhance
your life it is clutter and so it sounds
to me like you have a lot of things that
are clutter those things aren't you but
even the things that aren't clutter are
also not you they can be an extension of
your personality but even your
personality isn't necessarily you your
personality changes and morphs and
expands and contracts as you gain more
wisdom and become more mature but the
thing that I'm noticing here TK and
there's a bit of a theme for today
there's an emotional clutter here that
sits beneath the physical clutter if it
was just a physical clutter problem here
the answer would be so simple wouldn't
it oh yeah just get rid of the things
and then the Clutter will be gone but
you can get rid of the things there's
still something else that's under
pending that physical clutter and it's
the emotional clutter and you wrote
about this so well in emotional clutter
the new book you have out you want to
talk a bit about that that's right you
know anytime we use the pursuit of
things or the possession of things which
is something that can happen to people
who have and people who lack things
as a substitute for the filling of
belonging The Filling of purpose The
Filling of meaning then we divorce the
creative process from the process of
consumption in a way that leads to this
consumerism and that becomes a form of
emotional clutter that eventually
manifests itself in the form of the
physical clutter and once all that
physical clutter piles up we say man I
feel so bad about this but the problem
started long ago before the Amazon boxes
piled up before the all the different
possessions filled up your room the
problem started back when you said I am
going to look to that thing to be for me
what only I and my creative power can be
for me right and so that's that's part
of the emotional aspect of this and one
of the things I would say is as we've
often talked about before consumption is
simply when you use resources to meet
needs and desires an innocent natural
process consumerism is when
we divorce the creative process from the
process of consumption in a way to where
we're using one thing to compensate for
the other so when you ask this question
how can I replace these items without
falling back into consumerism I would
say the fall into consumerism has
already occurred that is what happened
when you made the choice to buy things
that were not a reflection of who you
really are but in order to please others
or fit in or just fit into this world
that says you got to have it because
it's on sale or because other people
will appreciate you having it that was
the fall into consumerism what you are
doing now as you are evaluating that
decision and you're checking in with
your feelings and saying this doesn't
really line up with me I don't feel
right about it that's the creative
process and so getting out there and
finding things that you really want that
will properly embellish your home in a
way that has the function and the
aesthetic that you desire and then
letting those other things go that's the
creative process so you're already
involved in the creative process I would
simply give myself permission to immerse
myself into it more fully and to Simply
let go of the fact that I may have made
a mistake in the past those choices
already made those costs have already SP
been spent let's do the best that we can
moving forward to find out what we do
like based on our own values and then
let the other stuff that we don't need
that was about other people go what
emotions do you hear coming up in this
question for me there is obviously the
regret of the things from the past yep
and one way to let go of the regret is
to let go of the things that continue to
remind you of the regret oh I can't
believe I bought that stupid thing but
once it's out of sight quite often it
does become out of mind once you've
actually let it go maybe there's a bit
of insecurity here like oh I won't be
complete without these things so there's
that emotion as well what are what what
other emotional clutter are you
witnessing from a question like this I I
I I I sense a little bit of fear and
self-doubt uh the the fear component
is and I know what I want to do going
forward but I'm afraid that since I've
already made this mistake in the past I
might get stuck in this cycle of
consumerism that I know doesn't reflect
my values there's a little bit of that
fear and that fear is springing from
some self-doubt which is I made a
mistake before I might end up making a
mistake again and I think the solution
to the fear is the same as the solution
to that self-doubt and that's trusting
yourself trusting yourself in two ways
number one trusting in your ability to
learn from past mistakes when you make
decisions that don't serve you you have
the ability to look at that as feedback
to upgrade your knowledge and say all
right I can make a more informed
decision next time you got to trust your
ability to learn and the second thing is
you've got to trust your taste you know
what feels good to you you know what
looks good to you you know what smells
good to you and even though in the past
you may have made decisions based on
what looks smells and feels good to
other people you can trust that your
taste and following those things are
what's going to bring you the highest
satisfaction what you're bringing up
there is actually the flip side of
they're just not me the items that I I
bought brought into my life they're just
not me all you're really saying there
let's uncouple it from they're not me
they don't adhere to my preferences to
my tastes to my desires to the way I
want my home to look right now maybe
they actually did adhere to the way you
thought you wanted your home to look and
it didn't work out for whatever reason
or just like someone who built a brand
new kitchen in the
1990s and still has that kitchen today
it might feel out of dat to them and
that's okay what do we do in those
scenarios we simply let go we stop
holding on to the thing that is creating
this other emotion in us which is misery
or discontent which is obviously an
emotion that is underpinning this
question yeah because you hear the
discontent not only with the stuff that
she purchased but I don't even know
where to go from here and that's another
emotion that you're experiencing here is
the uncertainty and what I'll tell you
is that quite often uncertainty is
beautiful when we don't have too much of
it uncertainty is a great seasoning now
some people like more uncertainty than
others just like some people like
spicier food than other people some
people like oh I want all the
uncertainty I want to go skydiving and
rock climbing without ropes and whatever
it is they want that uncertainty they
don't even call it uncertainty they call
it variety or novelty or excitement and
so we all need a certain amount of
uncertainty where it goes wrong is when
we inject too much inert uncertainty
into our daily lives that we no longer
feel safe well there's also a
distinction between psychological
certainty and philosophical certainty
Psych olical certainty is the sense of
knowing what feels right to me I have
psychological certainty about the fact
that that movie was enjoyable to me
philosophical certainty refers to the
logical certainty that we desire to have
based on the ability to construct a
strong argument for it I have evidence
to demonstrate that this is true
sometimes you can have psychological
certainty about what you like or what
you want but you may not have
philosophical certainty in terms of your
ability to intellectually justify it to
another or prove that it's a reasonable
path to someone who doesn't have the
direct experience you have of your own
feelings and so you've got to give
yourself permission to know at a
visceral level what feels right for you
in terms of what you want to go after
what you want to pursue without
requiring the philosophical certainty of
being able to prove to anyone that
that's going to work 10 years from now
or that that's going to look impressive
or that that's the only or most Superior
way to do things no all thank you for
your question I would encourage you to
download TK's new ebook it's called
emotional clutter theminimalists.com
emotional clutter or you can listen to
the audio book version as well we did a
little mini podcast between every
chapter of that Audi book TK and I came
in the studio with Professor sha and
Alabama and we recorded a little podcast
sort of commentary about each chapter
unpacking these different types of
emotional clutter and finding ways to
let go of all of those emotions that
simply get in the way I hope you enjoy
that highlight if you'd like to see
another one check out this video right
here if you like to see that full
episode check out this video here or if
you'd like to dive deep into the full
private podcast subscribe via the
patreon link in the description your
support on patreon is what allows us to
keep this podcast 100% advertisement
free